well let's get more now on brexit talks
as the foreign secretary tells sky news
that sunday will be a point of
finality for brexit trade talks if the
eu does not move
substantially in negotiations last night
boris johnson shared a three-hour dinner
with european commission president
ursula van der leyen in the hope of
breaking
months of deadlock well i'm joined now
by nigel farage uh leader of the brexit
party but
is it the brexit party or is it reform
uk now mr farage
well we've applied to the electoral
commission to change the name to reform
uk and we're awaiting an answer which we
expect by next wednesday so i think
technically you're quite right to say
brexit party for now
okay um so we heard from us
in the last few minutes really last half
hour we've also heard from both
the uk and the eu that they have no deal
contingency plans in place
uh that will allow planes to continue
flying potentially
keep fishing going are we now in a
position where no deal looks
worse than a bad deal well let me just
say that the contingency planning from
the european commission on fishing
is that things carry on the same next
year as they have this year which would
mean
the french getting 90 percent of the
haddock quota in the southwest so i
think that's actually
a huge insult yet again
the position is very simple the european
union
will not change their position why
because in october last year
boris johnson went to brussels and
signed something that we in this country
call the withdrawal agreement
but which they call the new eu treaty
and treaties in brussels are are rather
like the bible
um and they're not gonna budge and so
boris johnson
having signed up to a set of wholly
unsuitable conditions but he was able to
sell it in the uk because we were
suffering from brexit and
here he was it's an oven ready deal it's
all going to be great
and then when he got to the general
election and he was under pressure
he then effectively contradicted what
he'd signed a few weeks before
so this is the mess we're in after four
and a half
years of a conservative prime minister
and boris johnson's choice now on sunday
if indeed that
is the deadline although one does notice
that word is a fairly movable feast
but if sunday is the deadline boris
johnson's choice is simple
either he goes along with what he signed
in october last year in brussels all we
do walk away
um it's all his fault then is it
well i'm not saying it's all his fault
but i think that the european union
uh you know from the start have never
really
wanted to talk about a free trade
agreement indeed you know
even on wednesday this week ursula von
de leon was saying i look forward to
meeting boris johnson
to discuss our partnership agreement in
capital letters
they don't want a simple free trade
agreement and i'm afraid what boris
signed up to
wasn't a simple free trade agreement if
boris johnson wanted
a canada star relationship he should
never have signed
what he called his oven ready deal so so
there is fault on both sides
when you look at what potentially could
happen at the end of this year we
already know that there are big
delays at the ports uh real problems
there we know that lots of
lorry drivers have returned to their
homes in eastern europe now that that is
partly due to covid not entirely due to
brexit
uh but there is huge concern from all
sorts of industries from the transport
industry we saw
uh a report out at the weekend from the
cabinet office that was leaked that
showed that fuel prices and food prices
inevitably will go up
in in the months following do you feel
any
sense of remorse do you feel that
perhaps if you hadn't started all of
this
we wouldn't be in this position no we
should have left four years ago
we should have left four years ago and
whatever short-term bumps in the road
there may or may not have been
should have been dealt with then i i
think it's been happening there are
people who are worried about losing
their livelihoods and and it's been a
heck of a year for all of us hasn't it
with covert
this is more than just on the road for
so many people it certainly has
that there is no question look when it
comes to transport chaos kent is used to
that
operation stack with 30 mile cues on the
m20
i'm afraid it's a common occurrence uh
because we get gales in the channel or
we get the french fishermen protesting
we are used to that but we are living we
are living in the 21st century
where any any sort of customs
declaration can simply be done
on an iphone you can see that on the
american
canadian border it's not that difficult
when it comes to businesses that would
suffer a short-term hit
on tariffs well look at it this way if
the eu charges us tariffs
and we charge them tariffs we'll be
better off
to the tune of seven eight nine billion
pounds a year
so we will be able in the short term to
help anybody that is disadvantaged but
remember this
all the terrible predictions economic
predictions about what would go wrong
if we did if we even dared to vote
brexit none of those
have come true any short-term problem is
of course dwarf
anyway by the pandemic and by being free
of the single market by being able to
set our own regulation
i'm 100 confident that that's the path
to a more prosperous britain
in the next few years but the problem is
we haven't really left yet have we
the deadline hasn't really been reached
so how do we know
well we were told that even a vote to
leave would lead to economic disaster
which very clearly it did not
um and we've got to remember we've got
to remember
that the eurozone is only fifteen
percent
one five percent of global
gdp there is a great big one there's
only one fishing is only
less than one percent of ours so why do
you keep going on about it so much
because we voted to take back control of
our laws
and our borders and parts of that of
course are our territorial waters it may
be small
in economic terms but in terms of
symbolism it's very powerful indeed
um you've tried repeatedly to stand as
an mp and failed you tried a new kp
tribe at the brexit party
um do you think you're going to have any
success in with reform uk
do you know what i'm the only person you
will ever speak to who has won two
national elections leading two different
parties never in british history has
anyone done that before which i did in
the 2014
and 19 european elections when it comes
to breaking first past the post in
westminster
it is very very difficult uh the brexit
party
as you know uh fought a by-election in
peterborough last year
we lost to labor by 600 votes uh we
fought a long court case
over postal votes a theme which is quite
familiar
in american parliaments at the moment it
is difficult
there is no question are you saying that
the the democratic system in the uk
is is just like the democratic system in
america according to trump
really i think that whether is
large-scale postal voting there will
always be fraud
of that there is absolutely no doubt
anybody going to look at the number of
people who've gone to prison
in the last 20 years because of it look
i'm under no illusions
that to break the close shop of british
politics with this voting system
is a very very difficult thing to do but
what i also know is that ukip
had the most profound political change
on britain i mean literally
a conservative party that was remain is
now a conservative
party that is leave and it was the
pressure of ukip over many many years
that did that so
there are lots of ways of winning in
politics without necessarily
winning the very straightforward way
winning is getting more people to vote
for you and it seems that that that's
not
you're not being able to achieve that
within a constituency it is a simple
matter of persuading
more people to take your name than to
take somebody else's
well it just doesn't work like that
because under first pass it does work
like that
no it doesn't actually because under
first pass the post we tend to vote for
the party that we dislike the least
but the point i'm making yeah i mean
smashing the first past the post system
is really really hard but the point i'm
making
is that ukip only ever won two seats
in the westminster parliament but
completely changed
british politics and the course of this
country for the next few years so
so if we get a sellout you know from
boris johnson and let's see what happens
but
already we see big concessions on
northern ireland
the acceptance we're going to stay part
of the european arrest warrant
the acceptance that the european court
of human rights and strasbourg will
still be there
if we carry on down that route and this
is a sell-out
i don't think we're just going to walk
away because we're not
okay nigel farage always interesting to
talk to you thanks very much